all right we're gonna begin with this  breaking news from India where the most  powerful cyclone in years battered the  country's northeast coast overnight  cyclone Fani hit the low line region  with top winds above 125 miles an hour  where the 1 million people had been  evacuated ahead of this storm this is a  region where storms in the past have  killed thousands local officials say  there is significant damage and there  are reports at least three people have  died the storm is headed toward the  major city of Kolkata and it may reach a  refugee camp in Bangladesh where more  than a million people live we'll be  following the story all morning as we  get new developments